hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to I gotta
be honest it wasn't easy growing up as a
boy in the 80s and 90s
Who am I kidding yes it was but that's
because we had help we had help from the
women of our childhoods and we didn't
even know that they were helping us one
minute girls are just cootie field
loudmouth annoyances the next their
undeniable sex goddesses that make you
just want fall to your knees welcome to
the heavens and thank God that you're up
well you get the idea
girls went from annoying to attractive
in a matter of moments and we had
several steaming and amazing hotties to
make that transition easier for us they
were cool
they were smart they are high as hell
and that's why I am here to honor the
top 11 of them here today why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the top 11 animated
nostalgia hobbies
number eleven linka from Captain Planet
yeah yeah as much as I hate this show
you have to admit that little Russian
stroganoff was pretty damn attractive
she was cute strong they have one hell
of an attractive accent
saving God planet is yes a good thing Oh
God so what if she thought that all
Americans were uncommon distich
nicely Cynthia really dog that doesn't
mean she didn't drive us wild and with
the power of wind in her hands you can
tell this Soviet softie that she can
blow me away any day number 10 the
Baroness from a GI Joe though
technically working for Cobra the bad
guys on this show his fairness head is
all debating whether or not we should be
switching sides so why'd you join Cobra
the bareness me too hot isn't she this
build is was steaming with all black
attire skin tight latex sexy glasses and
a thick German accent I wasn't speaking
up a dog moron
oh I mean Russian accent oh I could get
a real kick out of that
or was it Scandinavian check Italian
Canadian either way this co broad is
hotter than a t 35 death rate and my
guess is she'll be having you shout out
Cobra sometime soon opener on number
nine Sailor Moon from well Sailor Moon I
have to admit I put her pretty low on
this list because I found this show just
so goddamn annoying even when I was a
kid I thought this show sucked I mean
the story makes no sense the characters
are all morons and they keep using the
same chunks of animation over and over
however if there were tons of animation
that they had to use over and over it
would definitely be the transformation
scenes I mean damn this is like an
intergalactic striptease actually the
funny thing about these scenes is that
they always take like two minutes to go
through all the transformations I mean
what the hell are the villains doing
during all that time all right Sailor
Moon I'm a big bad monster what are you
gonna do about it
Oh
nevertheless you can't argue with good
Japanese animation and their ability to
put women in skirts that are so short
they give new meaning to the term moon
power Sailor Moon from anime to animate
number eight harley quinn from batman of
all the characters in the world you
think that joker would be the last
person who would need a sidekick
but when one of the writers suggested
that one of the Joker's henchmen should
be replaced when the henchwoman instant
history was made and thus Harley Quinn
would born an energetic totally
psychotic airhead who had the hots for
the Joker aka would since then Harley
has gone on to start up even getting
herself her own comic book series so
what is it that makes her so damned
attractive is it her energetic
personality is it her figure and that
skin tight outfit my guess is it's
because she's going out with the Joker
which gives the rest of us homicidal
maniacs who are dreaming of love
much-needed hope do tell there's no
doubt about it
Harley Quinn gives new meaning to the
term crazy wrong you know that boss
number 7 hello nurse from Animaniacs if
more nurses look like this I probably go
to the doctor more often with her 40s
tile dress long slinky legs and hot
killer body
she's the cartoon character that made
sexual harassment fun again and even
helped coin the phrase hello nurse
yes okay so I don't think this phrase
ever actually caught on but it was
definitely used in the show a lot she
was always the object of Yakko and Wakko
affection which always left out with
okay that's kind of creepy
hello lenders she's every patients dream
come true number six
chitara from Thundercats if Angelina
Jolie and chester Cheetah ever had a kid
she had cesare she looks something like
this
faster than lightning and just as hot
cheetah was just as exotic as she was
erotic and trust me when I say she gave
new meaning to the term fast pussy come
on my hands down she was fierce dominant
and made the roadrunner look like a
handicapped turtle chitara if she
doesn't make your sword grow nothing
will easy for you to say number five
Daphne from scooby-doo talk about a
character who did absolutely nothing
she never solved any mysteries never
found any clues but goddamn could she
wear that purple dress so what if she
has the personality of a hair spray can
she was the only thing as scooby-doo
that was appealing to look at how do you
think about it
Velma's a lesbo Shaggy's a stoner
Scooby's dawn and Fred well I just don't
trust anyone that wears an orange
neckerchief and I don't think you should
either
Daphne was the only character that you
actually look forward to see you she was
colorful polite and of course hot as
lava Daphne she may not have a clue but
I'm sure she has several restraining
orders you shouldn't believe everything
you read
number four April O'Neil from Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles talk about a true
damsel in distress
there wasn't one second of this show
where she didn't need saving oh but
despite that she was a pretty fun
character she was cynical she was funny
and let's not forget that skin tight
yellow jumpsuit I mean one reporter wear
skin tight yellow jumpsuits it makes no
sense I can tell you right now though if
more reporters wore skin tight yellow
jumpsuit I would know everything that's
going on in the world I would watch the
news so much you'd had to pry me away
from those jumpsuit wearing journalist
well maybe not all of them but
nevertheless April was always the damsel
who got herself into trouble and yet you
always look forward to saving she was
quick
feisty clever and always knew how to
make the green boys turn bred April
O'Neill making us all pop out of our
shells
number three rope from x-men there's
nothing like a little southern comfort
to call me it down and road was
definitely that with her sizzling
accented southern personality ro was
always that forbidden fruit that you
could never touch literally if you touch
her you go into a coma for the rest of
your life but hey that just made us
wonder more she could fly she was strong
she was smart and of course she was
saucy ER that texas prime rib on
barbecue night funny a lot of men don't
like the idea of women being stronger
than them but in rose case she can kick
my flabby white ass any day in the mood
for a hot date if there was ever a xxx
men you can assure yourself that rogue
would definitely get top billing
you can drain my energy anytime chef
number two Ariel and Jasmine from the
Little Mermaid and Aladdin it's hard to
choose which one of these fairy tale
beauties was sexier so I just gave them
both their own number two spot I mean
these two hotties make Barbie look like
Betty Crocker with their big wide eyes
and soft curvy lines there's no doubt
that doesn't he definitely knew how to
make our dreams come true now a lot of
you might be wondering why didn't I put
Belle on there well it's not that she
wasn't beautiful smart and a
well-developed
character it's just that well she didn't
show her navel and on this countdown
that earned you like 20 more points
sorry kid
nothing personal now all three of these
beauties made their appearance at a time
when anime women were just concerned
about one thing more there's so much
why is it Disney women are never
satisfied you're fuckin royalty if you
had any more you'd be freaking gods but
nevertheless it was Ariel on jasmine who
were the exotic beauties
even though Ariel is technically a fish
which would make relationships difficult
but not impossible both of them were
active fun adventurous and willing to
show off their belly buttons Ariel and
jasmine the princesses of our hearts and
every other structured way currently
I've met and the number one enemy
nostalgia Adi is yeah man like I even
got to say her name there is no doubt
about it
Jessica Rabbit is the most attractive
thing ever drawn on paper with her thick
luscious lips half-shut eyes and long
red hair Jessica Rabbit at everyman
jealous of a stinking cartoon character
come on Roger let's go here a big gift
carrot cake
that fucking rabbit and of course you
can't overlook that phenomenal body
which I don't think could technically
exist in real life let me think about it
if the breasts are twice the size of her
waist and yet her waist is half the size
of her legs she would probably fall to
the ground unable to keep her balance
but fucking we didn't care she willed
unbelievable
the ultimate femme fatale she was
mysterious erotic and knew how to ten
men in fact she might have tempted them
too much there's an infamous
controversial scene where Jessica's
flung out of the car where she exposes
herself not once but twice in a matter
of seconds this scene caused so much
controversy that they actually
re-released it on video and blocked out
the image covering it with her dress
well if an animated woman is so hot that
even the animators had to see her naked
chances are she really does deserve the
number one spot Jessica Rabbit I'm not
bad I'm just drawing that way really
drawing that way and those are the top
11 anime nostalgia honey's if you got
some laughs out of this thanks for
watching if you got aroused by any of
this they're not real
for God's sake seek some help I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to